Bladesmiths,
congratulations, you've
made it into the third
round of this competition,
and now it's time to send
you back to your home
forges to recreate this
iconic weapon from history.
That weapon is
Charlemagne's Joyeuse.
Today we are pre-testing
Charlemagne Joyeuse.
The Joyeuse was supposed to be
a sword wielded by Charlemagne.
And it is your standard sword
that, as you look at it,
it's quite decorative
because it's a homage
to the great Charlemagne.
NARRATOR: Meaning
joyful, the Joyeuse
is considered one of the
most famous swords in history
and was the personal
sidearm of King Charlemagne.
After the fall of
the Roman Empire,
Charlemagne used
the blade in battle
to reunite Western Europe.
Covered in gold jewels
and floral patterns,
this weapon was light
and deadly and earned
the reputation as the sword
that conquered Europe.
Featuring a double edged blade
with a deep central fuller,
the sword was also rumored
to have magical powers,
like the ability to shine
brighter than the sun.
Today, the legendary
sword can be
seen on display at the Louvre.
So when we test
a weapon that's
tied to a historical
figure, I try
to embody the feeling of who
that historical figure was.
When did he live?
How did he fight?
[music playing]
So that way, it ties
into the kind of weapon
that I'm wielding.
At the same time, it gets
me into character, I guess.
I try to embody the
spirit of who they were
and how they fought.
So we had some weapons like
Genghis Khan or the barbar--
fighting like a barbarian, or
we had General Patton's sword.
And of course, now we have
Charlemagne's Joyeuse sword.
[music playing]
So with this
particular weapon, we
actually engage
multiple targets,
which they do in combat.
It's not just a one and done.
Now when you create
that kind of scenario,
it allows me to truly test
the balance of the weapon.
When I say "balance,"
it's not only
just the weapon in my hand,
it's how do I move with my legs
with it, when I'm moving around
attacking different targets.
Every time you move,
it really gives you
information about how
the weight of that weapon
will affect the way you move.
This is a multi use
weapon, so I wanted to see
how many different ways
can I cut, can I thrust,
can I chop with it.
Pre-testing the
Joyeuse against a boar
really gives us
information of that edge,
how well it can cut thick hide.
[music playing]
Sure was a lot of fun.
It will kill.
Good luck, we'll
see you in four days.
[music playing]
So I'm going to use a big
piece of 5160 bar stock.
It can take a lot of
damage and flex well.
I want to make sure I got
the length of the blade
done down to a reasonable size.
So this steal is definitely the
most awkward thing that I've
ever worked with in the shop.
It's like a big wet noodle.
I'm going to weld up a
15 layer Damascus fillet
and make a Swiss
pattern Damascus.
I think it'll really set the
sword up for a nice look.
So I got the forge
weld set, and I'm
going to draw it out to length.
[music playing]
Now that I have my
pieces all shaped,
I'm going to start heat
treating the blade.
So I get my sword up to
the perfect temperature,
and I'm ready for quench.
And I pull it out, and
it's just beautiful.
[laughs]
It feels amazing to have
a fully quenched blade.
So my biggest fear of
putting in this fuller
is just grinding right
through my blade.
And I can kind of tell
how close it is just
by feeling it with my hand.
After about an hour,
the fuller is done,
and everything is looking good.
Coming out pretty well.
Now I can work on profiling
the pommel and guard
and getting them exactly
to where I want it.
For my handle, I
choose diamond wood
because it can take
a lot of abuse,
and it's not going to break.
[music playing]
I'm in the homestretch now.
It's a good looking piece.
MITCH: We're going to
start out with a bar
of 1075 high carbon steel.
We're going to do a lot
of the quick forging
to shake with the power hammer.
Whenever you try to move a
big piece of metal like this,
it's quite a challenge
to keep it straight.
[rumbling]
Whoa.
It's getting long and
heavy and hard to hold.
It's cooling down between
a couple of 2 by 6s,
so that way it doesn't
warp as it cools down.
Now we're going to get
ready for heat treatment.
Getting pretty close to
coming up the temperature,
so we're about
five minutes away,
and we'll be quenching it.
This is it.
And then, my hand
cramps, and I drop
the blade into the quench tank.
Well.
I'm worried about that hitting
the bottom of the quench tank
did some damage.
Come on, man.
I tried to fish it out,
but, unfortunately, I
didn't catch anything.
Ended up pouring it out in the
five gallon bucket in my yard.
I got the blade out,
so it's all good now.
I did pick up a slight
warp close to the tip.
I should be able to
straighten that out there
in the temper cycle.
So time will tell.
My biggest focus is going to
be getting the blade straight,
and so I want to get that out of
the way and then go from there.
My solution is to extend
the width of the jowls
with some angle iron,
heat it up, and use
some wooden dowels to
put the proper pressure
where it needs to be.
She's straight.
Oh, that's so freaking awesome.
Now I need to make the handle.
Time's running out, so
it's a race to the finish.
[music playing]
She's getting there.
End of day 4.
Man, it's been quite a trip.
Everything turned out
great, a lot of hard work.
But I believe it really
paid off in the end.
[laughs] That's a
sword in four days.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
To find out how lethal
your weapons are according
to its historic design,
I will take your weapon
to deliver some killing
slashes and thrusts
on this poor carcass.
Mitch, you're up first,
you ready for this?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Mitch.
Let's talk about
your sword here.
Your edge coupled with a
weight that you have here
allows for very deep
cuts with every strike.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Peyton,
it's your turn.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah.
For this test, I'm
not too nervous.
I'm just excited to see
it happen, honestly.
I get to see this bore get
cut in half, hopefully.
[music playing]
All right, Peyton.
That was Joyeuse.
What I like about
this sword, it's
not just about the
edge or the point,
it's the balance of this.
I can actually use some
velocity, and it cuts deep.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
[music playing]
All right, gentlemen, it's
time for the strength test.
Now, to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades, I
will be attacking
our armored knights here.
Now this is not about
what your blades are going
to do to that target,
but what the target's
going to do to your blades.
Mitch, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- Yes, sir.
- OK.
Please don't break.
[music playing]
I think I just peed a little.
All right, Mitch.
Your edge did take
some damage here.
You can see the chip right
there and some rolls.
And your sword is heavy.
You know, this is a lot of
weight for a single handed
sword, more in the range
of a two handed sword
as far as the weight goes.
But she held up.
She's in one piece.
Good job, Mitch.
Thank you.
All right, Peyton, you're up.
You're ready?
Yeah.
[laughs]
One of those I
don't know which
way my head's going to go?
Yeah.
[music playing]
All right, Peyton.
It's weighty, but the weight
is all back in my hands,
so it doesn't feel as
heavy in the blade.
This sword has a much
better point of balance
than the other sword.
Your blade did take some
chips and some edge rolling.
But I think your
grinds are beautiful.
The sword is all solid.
You did a good job.
Thank you.
[music playing]
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the sharpness
test, the sandbag gauntlet.
Now, to test the
sharpness of your weapon,
I will slash across these bags.
Now, unlike the strength test,
this is all about how sharp
your blades are and how
well they cut these bags.
Mitch, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Mitch.
So despite some of the
damage of rolls and chips,
it wasn't an issue at all
in cutting these bags.
It will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Peyton,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Peyton.
The handle construction
is smooth but ovoid
enough to where I
wrap my hand around it
and I get a very good grip.
It will cut.
Thank you.
Mitch, Peyton, the judge's
deliberation is complete.
You guys have done fantastic
work on these finale weapons,
but there can only be one
"Forged in Fire" champion.
The new "Forged in
Fire" champion is
Peyton, congratulations, you're
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
Mitch, unfortunately, your
blade didn't make the cut.
Mitch, you brought us a
sword that performed well
in all three of our tests, so
this came down to the finer
points of craftsmanship
as in where
to place the balance
point on that blade
and the general weight.
That balance point being so far
forward made it harder to wield
and harder to
control, and that's
why we're letting you go.
I understand.
Mitch, you've been
a great competitor
of this entire competition,
but at this time,
I have to ask you to please
surrender your blade.
MITCH: Obviously, a
little disappointed.
Overall, happy with
what I turned in,
and I'm happy for Peyton.
If I had to lose to anyone,
I'd just sooner lose to him.
[music playing]
Peyton, congratulations, you
are the new "Forged in Fire"
champion, and that
is a title that
comes with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Please present your
sword to the judges.
I'm the next "Forged
in Fire" champion.
It's just crazy.
As soon as I heard my name,
it's just like a weight just got
pulled off my chest, just
like [sighs] it's over.
[laughs] Finally I can breathe.
[music playing]